wreckit-ralph is back on the big screen
the movie has a lot to unpack from its
two hour runtime and throughout this
video I'll be breaking down everything
that you need to know about the film
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know about
the film's ending or it's too
post-credit scenes then I suggest that
you turn off now but everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to though you might expect wreck-it
Ralph to to be packed with jokes and
gags the film actually has a really
emotional ending that pulls on your
heartstrings and sets of a sequel the
film itself continues the aesthetic of
the first film with the game characters
working on their respective arcade
machines during the day and taking the
night off vanellope and Ralph are still
best friends but the former is slowly
getting bored with her life
when her game sugar rush gets broken and
the replacement parts on eBay are far
too expensive to afford the two set off
into the Internet to find a fix Ralph
goes viral and vanellope changes games
and the two seem pretty well set up
until a virus ravages their machines and
the Internet
this virus causes clones of Ralph that
want to chase Penelope down and catch
her but eventually the two do manage to
defeat them without the internet being
destroyed with the internet saved
everything seems back to normal and
Ralph and vanellope take a long think
about what to do next
Ralph decides to go back to the arcade
and it looks like Penelope is about to
join him but she instead decides to stay
online in her new digital world it's a
real tear-jerking moment that to me
highlights how technology has moved
forward and thus separated us in some
ways sure the Internet is a good thing
in bringing people together but it also
pushes us apart okay I might be getting
a bit too deep now but anyway we see the
two chatting by video call and it's
clear that the two are still keeping in
touch so this may mean that we could see
them together again but that's not the
end of the film and both post-credit
scenes have some big moments
the first post-credit scene features new
Disney Princess Melania and in the scene
of a younger Moana is Shawn playing
again called pancakes and milkshake
in the game she has to feed it bunny and
a kitten but Ralph barges into it and
ruins it and it makes a nice little tie
into the larger Disney World the other
credit scene has a pop-up with a banner
that says click here to watch the frozen
2 trailer and when the link gets clicked
we get a Ralph's theme rickroll which of
course is another big Internet joke and
it's a nice way to close the film that
hints that Disney may be working on
bigger projects down the line so what
are your thoughts on Ralph breaks the
Internet did you enjoy the film and did
you prefer it to its predecessor comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video then please like it and check
out my breakdown of this week's other
big movie creep - this is a channel for
people who are mad into movies so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
that you've been the best and I'll see
you next time take care peace
[Music]